si jamais il faut reconnaître cette
qualité à emmanuel macron c'est que il
assume ses choix y compris le plus
symbolique d'entre eux c'est à dire la
suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune
oui c'est vrai qu'il assume ses choix il
a un côté très pédagogue même moi ce que
je voulais dire c'est que ce qui m'a
marqué c'est qu'il a dit qu'on était un
pays où il y avait des passions tristes
et de l' envie de la jalousie
à partir de là je pourrais vous avez des
riches oui la vie des riches il l'a dit
pour ça je pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet
sur la façon dont sans doute emmanuel
macron ne sais pas où placer la question
de l'argent et dont il n'est pas
conscient du fait que dans notre société
la façon dont l'argent manque pour les
services publics pour un certain nombre
de projets pour lorsqu'on est dans une
situation un peu précaire donc son
plaidoyer il est remarquable et j'allais
dire il aurait pu gagner le concours
d'éloquence à sciences po
mais le sujet s'est ensuite quand on est
président de la république comment
est-ce qu'on s'adresse à l'ensemble de
la société en prenant en considération
le fait que l'argent manque sans doute
dans des secteurs très stratégique j'ai
déjà dit ici mais que supprimer 3
milliards et demi d'argent public parce
qu'on supprime l'impôt sur la fortune
moi je pense que c'est pas que c'est pas
anodin donc traiter la question de
l'argent comme si quelque part elle
était juste une question de jalousie
sociale
ça me dérange et donc moi je pense qu'il
n'est pas devenu le président je réponds
à votre question que vous m'avez pas
posée mais le président d parrish
d'ailleurs les pas riches parce que
c'est cesser les classes moyennes et les
classes moyennes supérieures les parrish
du tout il n'est pas devenu le présent
les paris du tout mais moi par exemple
je suis une peut-être une parrish
moyenne n'est pas devenu mon président
après cette intervention j'ai considéré
que la question de l'argent il semblait
en avoir une vision un petit peu de
d'enfants gâtés